Trump always called him Britain Trump um
is he what was we are there great
parallels
well there are you know there as always
with these things there are and there
aren't I mean the there aren't in the
sense that he's just given a resignation
speech today without threatening to
unleash a violent mob yes to ensure he's
his own uh I think even he would not
cross that line
um you know they were the the
um there was definitely you know a vein
of racist Prejudice that ran through
Boris Johnson's writings about you know
Muslims black women old black people
Muslim women and so on uh and you can
point to those in the writings I don't
think he weaponized race uh in the way
that
um Donald Trump did
um but the things that are in common uh
and we saw them even today actually is
this populist contempt for rules for
conventions for Democratic norms for the
rule of law his claim that he speaks and
embodies the will of the people that his
critics are somehow uh against all of
the people and despite a super
privileged background himself offering
himself as a Tribune of them of the
masses against the elite I mean in Boris
Johnson's case it's such nerve it's such
a cheek uh to pose that way when you
know he is absolutely a child of the
establishment and the elite but
nevertheless that's the appeal and the
central thing the defining is this uh
disregard contempt actually for truth
and that is what made them twins across
the Atlantic it is what um Donald Trump
saw I think it's why he saw uh Boris
Johnson as something of a kindred spirit
because
they both had that that willingness to
just lie and lie and lie and not even
you know break stride while doing it I
mean just to say whatever was helpful
for that minute even if it was untrue
and it is proven to be
Boris Johnson's undoing I mean it isn't
just that he appointed a man and
seriously accused of sexual misconduct
as his deputy chief whip it's that he
lied about his claim of ignorance of
that record clay not to have been
specifically told when he had and um you
know that this of course I think would
have been survivable had it not been for
partygate before and participate turned
again on lies it was the deception the
line that did it and that is what the
two of them absolutely haven't gone I I
I think we have to be slightly careful
there um I I don't regard Boris
Johnson's another Donald Trump
um the lies that he told were what I
would like to call procedural lies
um they were someone said the the
ability to say half the truth and keep
your fingers crossed behind your back uh
as against Donald Trump's Monumental
lies um and I mean by the Thousand Boris
it seems to me is a slightly different
phenomenon he's bit like um so he's a
he's a tough liar the lies aren't
desperately important
um they're somehow unavoidable and he
always thinks he can get away with them
but but um I don't think it's the lies
around did him really I think it's it's
a triviality and undoubtedly the sleeves
which which really undid him the feeling
that he was in office to look after his
friends
um to to to to to to reward his allies
uh to disregard ability to disregard
competence a general feeling that he was
he was blowing the Dignity of his office
uh and I think that that is what really
undid him I mean people fasting on their
lives for the lies a fact
um these other things are much more
nuances of office
um and I do think I do think because I
think it's now as a moment we might at
least be a little charitable
um I do think that the the the charm the
ability to persuade people these are
good chap even if he isn't
um the fact that whenever Boris went
people tended to smile uh they cheered
up a bit
um he's given politics a sort of a
lesson in lift which very very few
politicians in Britain although many
abroad do and it's the populist in him
uh I don't think populism as such is an
evil thing it's an evil thing when it's
abused but I do think he showed us
um but popularity and politician um is a
matter of personality and style uh and
it did deliver for him for say for three
years
so he this is why Guardian readers do
Delight in our paper because the
guardian writers often see the world
very very differently
um I do disagree quite strongly with all
of that I mean partly because I think
it's
um Sam makes a really interesting point
about Charisma and and appeal and I
absolutely agree with him that he had
that uh Boris Johnson by the bucket load
that people will take away from this
anything positive about that I think the
opposite will happen I think people will
uh run a mile from the idea of I don't
think voters by the way but I mean other
politicians and others will think this
is not a model to follow
um because he will be a warning uh he'll
be a cautionary tale about the power of
the charismatic leader yes people will
say this guy can crack a joke or this
woman can deliver a good speech but look
where that got us last time you know
um he was because Boris Johnson was that
was all he was he was all performance
all shtic all Charisma
um it will be a warning don't be fooled
Again by that because even with a I mean
let's just think on this even with an 80
seat majority he's unraveled and the
government itself is is at Breaking
Point
um that's an amazing thing to do and
that's because of in a way that that all
he had was performance and shallowness
so I think he's he's going to serve as
an advertisement against those that
Suite of political skills I would also
say just something about populism I mean
I think this idea that he's a tough liar
is in a way what helps him and it's a
very British thing which is we don't
realize when someone is a kind of Victor
all band figure or a Donald Trump figure
because they sound and look like one of
the good one of the chaps and he had
that eaten accent and so it we didn't
think we couldn't think of him as a
Sinister sort of bolsonaro type figure
or whatever but it was a mistake because
there were big lies there and I would
say too one is I think brexit is a
project founded on big lies the live at
350 million on the side of the bus but
also that we could stop trading in a
free trade area with our closest
neighbors and it would somehow make us
richer massive lie but also the party
gig wasn't about the bits and pieces
about partying it was about saying to
people these are the rules we're all
following them these are life and death
rules that will deprive you of contact
with your loved one
and I'm laughing behind my hand because
I'm not keeping them at all that's
there's nothing tough about that lie or
gentle about that lie that was a really
deep attack I think on on how people
lived and made really grave decisions
where they said I'm not gonna bid
farewell to my dying father or mother
because the rules don't let me and they
are now two years later and they will
for years forever think I was a fool
because of what that man was doing so I
think they're serious to lives that
Boris Johnson lies you know they're
different from the Donald Trump lies
not as serious as overturning a
democratic election but pretty brave